Do you think that a sexual relationship
without consent is 1 rape ?
Well, apparently,
for uh,
Emmanuel Macron,
1 sexual relationship without consent is not 1 rape
since with his colleague Victor Orban,
he managed to obtain
the removal of the definition of rape
of the Directive
European Union to fight against
violence against women.
Emmanuel Macron shows at this hour
and here in the European Parliament all the
he has for women's rights
and moreover
it is not enough at its first fact of work
since he thinks that
women's uteruses must be
rearmed for its demographic rearmament.
And he said that,
uh.
1 man,
Gerard of God accused of rape,
made France proud.
Well,
what would make France proud
would be that we defend
here means of fighting violence
made to women
and say very clearly,
1 sexual relationship without consent is 1 rape.
I repeat
voluntarily here so that it is so said in these
institutions and to all women in Europe,
we tell them that here we fight
for 1 sexual relationship
without consent is well defined as such
and as 1 rape.
And this obstruction
made by France is scandalous